one of the biggest mistakes you've made
on the first day of shooting I think
some of the biggest mistakes I've made
on the first day of shooting usually
pertain to interpersonal things at this
point I kind of know what I need to do
to get something done technically I know
the story I know all of the different
pieces that I need to deploy to
hopefully have a good film and the first
day obviously sets the tone for many of
those things right you have sometimes
people you've worked with hundreds of
times and then sometimes you've got
people that are brand new that you've
never seen before
and so when you're doing that I think
you have to figure out how those
relationships that you have existing are
going to mesh with those that are new
and so it's figuring out the
interpersonal dynamics of how these
people tick what makes them tick
deciding what they think is funny or not
funny things like that because that tone
you set on your set on the first day it
does not matter what the film is it can
be anything you're shooting an ad a
documentary film whatever that is going
to set the tone with that person that
doesn't know you for the rest of the
shoot and if you blow that and I have
before by misjudging someone and and
kind of what they you know how they feel
about things whatever it may be it's
been gotta be work on you to get that
back to get them back and so I think
that that maybe for me personally the
most that's not bad messed up before I
tried to do better about now well then
that's big of you to admit that you
misjudge but there are also people that
look for challenge and they see someone
in charge or whatever and whatever
they're dealing with and they're like no
I'm gonna be the thorn in the side for
this whatever you think and some people
definitely have that I try to meet as
many people as possible across as many
departments as possible the
or shooting something to kind of get a
sense of people and how they are and if
there's someone that I think is so
egregious I'll talk to a department head
and say let's cut this person I've done
it and and so you know that tone and and
tone and climate in a in a set to me is
very important that starts at the top it
starts with me if you set a good tone if
you set a good atmosphere for your cast
for your crew typically even if you are
working on lower budget or if someone's
not being paid as well whatever it is
they will work better because they like
the space they're in and so it is on me
as director to set that tone if I'm
heinous or if I come in with a bad
attitude that trickles now I'm very fast
and so it's really my job to figure out
what makes my crew and my cast tick and
once I understand the dynamics of that
then I have a lot more latitude to do
the things as I want oh yeah I don't
know if I would really see you being the
one Bruce I'll just say that but I'm
sure that there are I'm sure there are
people that worked with me they don't
like oh sometimes people don't like
someone for something that's not the
person's fault that's true so and I know
I'll be the one to say that so if if you
can send someone is trying to whatever
they want to be the director and they
are kind of like coming from the side or
doing things what's the best way to
diffuse some of that without having to
call a department and their ways of
course maybe not humor to get them right
well I try to figure out what again
makes that person tick and sometimes
it's just identifying little things like
they need this thing in craft services
right it's sometimes figuring out that
they love this type of coffee and having
a PA go get it for them whatever it may
be it's sometimes just little things
it's observations right so even a little
observation like that can go a long way
to make someone feel wanted and needed
on a set because I think that when
people want to take charge it's not
usually because there
nating bully on the set it can be
usually it's because they think you're
not competent I think that usually
that's the reason that people try to do
that and so if you display competency if
you're calm if you know what you want to
do I am this may be shocking to you but
I'm usually not hot-headed and so I keep
a very even tone even with myself even
if I'm not in a good mood or if I'm
tired whoever it is I try not to project
that on to the set because I know that
will then trickle down so I try to find
the things that that person needs to
feel comfortable on set even if it's a
creature comfort like a coffee or a
crafty thing but then it's also just
making sure that they understand that I
understand what I'm doing I've been very
lucky that I haven't had that happen
recently but earlier in my career for
sure I definitely had to deal with that
with actors and end people working on
the film for sure and I have learned
from those lessons and know that I have
to make sure my shits together before I
can tell all these people what to do and
how to do
you